His guys good morning
Welcome back to our channel
Especially today's vlog of umbrella friends is fast
Let's just update because
Something has already been released
Advisor
Or announcement of ours
Bureau of
It's about the changes that will happen
That our Filipino compatriots will go through
Isn't it going home to the Philippines
It is
Effective
Or will start
Aspril one
Twenty four so listen carefully
Who is affected net we will repeat everything
International Filipino
Passengers
You go through everything too
International
Ports of entry
Isn't it going to be processed
Through e
Gates or those
Electronic Gates
That we call it according to
Announcement
The one will be deleted
Arrival
Sticker
Isn't it if you've been through
Electronic gates
So this is the process of
Electronic Gates
That's ours in the Philippines
Aren't you going to pass by
Isascan is the one
Boarding pass
The passport
You will make a mark
Will be painted like that
And when you go out before you go out
There is already a
Arrival
ah sticker where the one
That's a sticker
We will stick it on the blank page of ours
So that's it
They announced
Is the beginning
Since april one is
The one will be deleted
arrival ah
That's a sticker and in exchange for that
We can only receive
Arrival
Confirmation
Where
Be there in the email
address
We put it
When we registered in e
Travel before us
Go home to the Philippines okay
It is hoped
That is clear
If you have any questions
Just put it in ours
Comment section below right?
Not with
Standing
The Bureau of
Immigration
Arrival
Border stamp
We can still
Can't you request it
Border stamp
You will seal ours
Passport
May be a fixed
On to the philippine
Passport
By the immigration
Officer Officer
Assigned
At e gates
upon
Request so if you request to seal the one
Your passport
It's possible
Stamp that with
Immigration
Officer assigned there to
Election gates
This is another reminder
From our
Bureau of
Immigration
It is said that for the quick processing of those
Passengers
Isn't the Philippines going home?
We are all
Isn't it ordered?
To register
Isn't it or update our
Information on e
Travel system
At least
Seventy two hours prior to the
Travel intended
Oh that
So this is just my opinion
It's just a little sad here
In the process
We got home to the Philippines is where
It's a bit of a memorizer
Our countrymen are the ones
Formerly e
Travel right?
Using the one
website only
Where we have mastered
I think they will introduce
These new ahs
System with
Ego of that ph
That's it
It's just sad because
I know we all know that there are so many versions
e has been through so much
It's traveling but there's nothing we can do
But comply with what it is
Travel
That is being implemented in the Philippines
好的
Isn't it like that?
Ash to those who ask how to regenerate
What to call this
ah qr code
That's where the new e
That's travel
Did something
We video
I will put it in the comment section of this video
On our youtube channel guys
Ah you will watch it
That's the beginning of unloading the
Ego of ph
Isn't it igniting up
And then verifying our account
Until
Itravel generation
qr code
That's what we made a panrequest
Our countrymen also have a guide at least
They have a guide
When they register
That's where e travel is
At least
Three days or
Seventy two hours prior
To our departure
From the country we came from
That's just our quick
Update on today's
Umbrella friend's vlog thank you guys
Always stay safe and god bless ready